bonjour à tous je me présente faille ce
danseur hip hop et chorégraphe de la
compagnie ngb matic j'ai à peu près une
minute pourront parler du projet non
printemps 2020 dans lequel je vous
présente mon challenge numéro un en vous
inspirant des gestes barrières créer
votre propre chorégraphie préventive
stop communisme comme cet artiste et
sont nombreux à se joindre à l'opération
mon printemps 2020 lancée ce 22 avril
par l'académie de versailles
le principe est simple un artiste un
défi libre ensuite aux élèves en
autonomie ou avec leurs enseignants
s'ils sont investis dans l'initiative
d'y répondre
théâtre cinéma photographie musique
danse tous les arts sont concernés et
puis nous allons faire en sorte que nos
jeunes s'intéressent à des thématiques
qui sont particulièrement importantes en
ce moment le temps qui passe
la mémoire le dedans et le dehors la
liberté la solidarité la solitude
ce rendez vous permettra aux plus jeunes
de prendre du recul sur cette période de
confinement mais aussi d'en garder une
trace en souvenir
cette création a pas une vertu
individuelle de construction de
résilience dans cette commune était là
mais je cistes beaucoup aussi si on peut
voter de sa vertu dans leur rapport à la
société si l'épreuve collectif on vit et
on trouvait ça très intéressant et
important de connecter l'expérience de
la création individuelle avec la société
avec le reste du monde parmi les
partenaires
l'opéra national de paris le muséum
national d'histoire naturelle ou encore
le réseau ile-de-france des musiques
actuelles
la plateforme l'umih point fr relaiera
les créations d'artistes et d'élèves une
publication sera également fait sur le
compte instagram mon printemps 2020
l'opération se poursuivra jusqu'à la fin
du confinement mais elle pourrait se
prolonger les mois suivants en fonction
des résultats